here
this is for the guy who introduces me
everybody in this audience has to get
one of these handouts okay just a single
page and uh and everybody needs one so
uh
okay
uh
um
they're just references
so uh
this is a talk about applications of of
uh
additive combinatorics and his joint
work with fernando chao
and sound erajan
in case i forget to say it and
it it it starts with a very primitive
problem
when we add numbers
in the usual way
that's 11 that's six so there's no carry
i'll put a zero there
this is eight there's no carry this is
five here this is zero there's a carry
and etc right this is zero there's a
carry this is 12 and there's a there's a
carry
when we add numbers in the usual way
carries occur along the top
yeah
yes there is occur along the top and if
you're me or most of you it's not an
unnatural question to ask how many
carries are there and how do they go
no that's a question and uh um
i won't say so much about it but
the process of carries if the digits are
chosen at random uniformly between 0 and
b minus 1 base b
the process of carries
is a markov chain
and it it has and if you add m numbers
it's still a markup chain because if i
if i tell you
the the carries process up to a point
what happened before doesn't matter and
just the just the the future depends on
the past only through the
immediate past and uh it's a an
interesting markup chain with
connections to all kinds of areas of
mathematics and
it it got me
thinking about carries so i want to talk
about carries a little bit um and let's
start with the carries matrix
so
i'm going to take just adding two digits
say 0 one
two
up to nine
zero one
up to nine those are my two digits if i
add zero to anything i don't get a carry
zero zero zero if i add one i only get a
carry if i add it to 9 so i'll i'll
write a carry i'll call it b but b is 10
here
i get a carry if i add it to 9 if i add
2 i get a carry if i add it to
9 or 8. and if i add 9 well
b
b
so it's this
part of the triangle and there are
b choose 2
carries
and so if you pick two numbers at random
uniformly between zero and b minus one
uh the chance that you get a carry is
this which is one half minus one over
two b
and that's equal to forty five percent
if b is 10
so about half the time you get a carry
now
the next
stage given that
this turned out to be an interesting
subject i i tried to think about what
are carries after all
so that's a question
what are carries
um
well
if you think that you have
the group b
z
uh contained in z
for example
as
0 plus or minus b
plus or minus 2b etc
plus or minus
this
this is a subgroup of this group
and then
you choose coset representatives
and i'll choose the usual ones 0 1 up to
b minus 1.
that's what else would you do
then
unfortunately the sum of two coset
representatives isn't always a coset
representative so i plus j
well is is i plus j mod b that's what it
is plus what's called a factor set f i j
which which might be zero or b
so uh in fact carries
these you get a carry if uh if i plus
j is bigger than or equal to b
this this this is b and
this is b
otherwise um so carries are co-cycles so
that was the title of the of the talk
now once you say that sentence um there
are lots of directions open
to you
one
direction was
well this is a subgroup of a group i
chose co-set representatives chose this
one because everybody does uh
is there a better choice of co-set
representatives can can we do better
and by better i mean fewer carries in
some average sense and
in my first reaction to that question
was can't because otherwise
we know you know
well it turns out people didn't know
koshi knew people before koshi knew the
answer is yes
i found it surprising anyway um what are
called balanced coset representatives
namely zero uh plus or minus one plus or
minus two
plus or minus b minus one over two let
me suppose b is odd for for a moment
they do better so just
to point that out
let's do
when b is 5
and so
okay
so my coset representatives would be
minus 2 minus 1 0 1 and 2 minus 2 minus
1 0 1 and 2. okay so here comes the quiz
part of the talk okay
what we have to fill out the carries
matrix
so minus two and minus two is minus four
that's true
okay minus four is minus five plus one
so the carry if you add minus two and
minus two it's not a coset
representative is minus 5. and minus 5
minus 5 here and 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 if you
add 0 to anything you have no carry 0 0
0 0 0 here's 0 0 zero zero l five
one and two are three
which is five minus two okay and and
then zero zero zero five five
okay
there are six carries
there are six carries there they are
six is less than five choose two
and six carries
uh less than five juice 2 which is 10.
so balanced coset representatives do
better
so you can ask now once you make that
that leap
you can ask well can you do better
why do you have to have any carries
why
okay
so
uh an easy fact uh is that uh uh
fact um that's the best you can do uh so
in general if you are base b uh
if b is odd it's b squared minus one
over four uh in general and if you know
b is five that's 24 over four which is
six uh and so that's about half
of
of b choose 2. and and that's the best
you can do
the
any choice
coset representative
at least
b
squared
over 4 and take the floor
if you're working you know with an even
base
say
base 6 you would use 0 plus or minus 1
plus or minus two and then
you know plus three just put put in one
of them just
make them make them neat that way that
that's that's the best you can do uh
carries
so
this is a very easy argument but let me
let me do it because they the arguments
get less easy as we go on um so
proof of this fact
it's this is a fact about real numbers
uh uh say
um say x1 up to x
b let me put zero in
uh
or this b minus one um our distinct real
numbers
our coset representatives
um you will have to have this many
carries
with
say there are c positives
so let me call them 0 less than y1 less
than y2
less than yc
those are the positive numbers if i add
yc
to anything i get c carries if i add yc
minus 1 i get at least c minus 1 carries
yeah if i add y 1
i get at least one carry because i get a
carry from that
nope
okay
so
so y c gives
c
uh
y one
gives
one at least and so this gives
c choose two carries
forced on you
by
addition
similarly for the negative numbers
they have they induce carries uh
and
well it's it's
b minus
c choose 2 from the negatives
that's that's forced on you and so all
together whatever choice of numbers you
have
so it's one half
whatever it is c times c minus 1 plus
b
minus c
times
b minus c minus 1.
and
this if you do it is b squared minus 1
equals b squared minus 1 over 4
taking b to be odd plus a square term
something that's positive
c minus b minus 1 over 2 squared and
that's bigger than or equal to b squared
minus 4. so
any choice of coset representatives has
at least
b squared over 4 um carries
uh so so and and that's that's sharp by
by these
negative things
okay that gets us started uh in the in
the question of how many carries do you
have
this story makes sense
for any kind of a group any kind of a
group
so
this makes sense
the question makes sense
for any
g
and h
and i'll take h to be a normal subgroup
i'll talk about that in a second
suppose that h is a normal subgroup of
uh of a group g
and
at the moment let's suppose it has
finite index
so this group g mod h is finite
like
b z in z wherever it is
um so suppose you have a finite index
normal subgroup of a of a general group
let x be coset representatives x coset
representatives
you can ask
you know how many carries are forced um
and uh and and how that goes and most of
those questions are open
but as a as a notion of um of
how close x can be chosen to be a
subgroup so to have no force no extra
carries uh let c of x uh be equal to uh
the the number of pairs
ordered pairs x y um uh in x uh plus x
uh
such that x times y
is also contained in x
so that's that's the number of good
things that can happen and let me
normalize it by
to make it between 0 and 1. so if
if if this is 1
it means for every pair x and y x times
y is an x and so x is a group and so we
say the extension splits
if c of x is one
x is a group
and
so
the extension is said to split
um
so the
a theorem uh that we proved after a
while
of uh honing it down is the following
theorem uh
saying
that
well saying the following so
uh h is a normal subgroup of a group g
with finite index
so if
c of x the number of good things is
close to one is bigger than seven ninths
then the extension splits
then
there exists a subgroup k uh subgroup
such that
k times h is g and
they only intersect trivially k
intersect um h
is the identity
so the extension splits so
and this seven nice is sharp uh as you
can see by uh
seven nice
sharp
from balance carries
from um uh
uh c3 the integers mod three sitting
inside the integers mod nine and balance
carries
okay that that
there are two carries if you
choose balance coset representatives
so
this is a this is an example of
well
of a theorem and i think it's worth i
think people in this audience some
people know certainly very well but
this proof went through many variations
uh ben green was around stanford when
sound and i started on it and we first
proved it for the integers mod p inside
the images mod p squared using
bella gower cemetery and uh and so we
had a tower of twos and you know it was
just some impossible theorem nothing
like seven ninths it was some impossible
thing and then it got better and better
and now it's this okay so um so i want
to
i want to
talk about that for for a minute
um
because the best proof came from
computer science theory theorists
and
it gives exactly the the right answer
so the
the proof
the argument uses approximate
homomorphisms uh so the
the
the proof uses the notion of approximate
homomorphisms
and
i don't know the history of this subject
and one of the joys of being at a
conference like this is you get to see
your colleagues like luca and so luca
someday i'm going to ask you this
question and be prepared
this is just a warm up
i'm upsetting it in the uh which is you
know
why do you guys use this
okay that's uh what what's it about in
the computer science theory world but um
let me tell you what it what it is um so
if you have two groups
g
g1 and g2
are two groups and say g1 is finite
then
well a mapping
say
t
from g1 into g2
is
an epsilon homomorphism
uh
if
the probability
that
t
of g one
g
g prime these are both in g1
is equal to t of g
times t of g prime
probability means under the uniform
distribution is bigger than epsilon
that's just the definition so there's
some chance that it behaves as a
homomorphism two elements picked at
random in g1 that that that's true
um there's a a
very nice theorem
due to see if i remember ben or
coppersmith
luby
and ronit rubenfeld
which says that
if you have an approxim an epsilon
approximate homomorphism
so
if
t
is epsilon approximate
for epsilon bigger than seven-ninths
then
there exists an actual homomorphism
there exists a homomorphism
say fee from g1 into g2
such that um
the probability that they agree
t of g
is equal to phi of g
so that is the proportion of elements
the proportion of elements in g1 such
that these agree
is
bigger than or equal to some tau of
epsilon
and
where tau of epsilon's an explicit
function i hope can people see if i'll
just
if i write down there yes so tower of
epsilon
is the smallest root
of
some quadratic polynomial which maybe i
remember 3x minus 6x squared is equal to
1 minus epsilon
and and since you can solve that
equation you know what tau of epsilon is
but in particular um for uh epsilon
bigger than seven ninths a tau epsilon
is bigger than nine tenths uh
uh so
uh
uh
tau of epsilon
is bigger than uh 0.9 by 9 over 10.
so
this is a theorem that was
proved in the
world of
testing if a random number generator is
linear or
in testing program correctness or that
sort of thing um and but it's a very
nice theorem and uh we were in the
middle of our various variations of of
uh of the theorem that i stated over
there and we saw seven nights and we
said this theorem must imply we guessed
that seven nights was the right answer
this theorem must imply that seven
ninths is that this theorem must imply
that theorem so i wanna
show you how
this theorem implies in that theorem uh
so
proof of
proof
of
our
seven ninth theorem
and so i need
two groups so what am i given i'm given
uh a normal subgroup of a finite index
normal subgroup of a group g
and some choice of coset representatives
um
which uh uh
has
behaves well seven ninths of the time
um
okay so let let's let g1 be g mod h
that's a group and g2
is equal to g
and let the mapping t of uh well these
are cosets gh
be just equal to
x
where
g h
is equal to
xh
so
just
pick the coset representative that's an
element of g and that that's a
perfectly reasonable thing to do
and
that's our mapping and if you look
the fact that
the number of non-carries the proportion
of non-carries is bigger than seven nice
says exactly that this is a
so this
is
a
c of x approximate
homomorphism
uh just it's the same it's the same
statement
so by their theorem
there is an actual homomorphism
so
choose fee
and it's
not their theorem i mean fee is
reasonably explicit it's uh
it's
reasonably explicit uh
but um
which is
uh
you know from
as above okay choose choose an actual
homomorphism so fee is a homomorphism
um
from g1 into g
let k be its image
that's a subgroup equal the
image
fee of
g1
that's a that's a subgroup and that's
going to be our
that's going to be our subgroup
from their conclusion their conclusion
is
t and phi
are equal
bigger than nine tenths of the time
so we know
that uh
since they're equal they're equal so k
intersect x
where they agree
is
well
i mean
do a very important inequality
here uh
k
uh
is bigger than uh or equal to uh
well okay intersect x
okay that's certainly true
that's bigger than
uh or equal to nine tenths
um
uh the the the size of uh of x uh
which is uh g mod
k so that that's the
that's this
nine tenths right the the chance that
these two things agree
is bigger than and so i'm
the chance is
pick something in g1 at random and
that's the size of g1 so
so we have
that inequality going for us
and now
what is there to say
um
well
let's
let's see what there is to say so um
it's also the case i have a homomorphism
so by the first isomorphism theorem uh
um this k
um is is
equal to isomorphic ii um
uh
g mod h
uh
uh mod it's kernel
the kernel of fee
now if the kernel isn't just the
identity
its size is at least two
and that's bad right the size of k
you know is is now too small uh so
so okay
two is
two is bigger than nine tenths or anyway
this goes in the right way so
this inequality implies um uh that uh
the kernel of phi
is just the identity and um and so
uh
k
is equal to the size of x
that's the first good piece of news and
um
if
there's anything in the
non-trivial in the intersection
if
there exists some l which is not equal
to one
where l is contained in k and h
okay
then
for
any element in k
then
any
k and k
well
only one of
of k and k l
can be an x
right because x is coset representatives
and so it can't contain
two things that differ by a multiple of
of h but
that says that the intersection is uh is
is at most half of the the size of of of
x
so that says that uh the intersection uh
okay if if this were the case the size
of the intersection
is
is
is less than or equal to the the the
size of
x over two
and and that contradicts this inequality
two so there is no such l and so
and so the extension splits so
um so since uh the size of h times k uh
is equal to the size of h
times the size of k
divided by the size of the intersection
um the the the
sorry this should have been
this should have been
this should have been
this is fine
this is this
why am i
i want no i want that this is one i know
that that's okay it's okay
so
so this size
this is trivial and and and the
extension splits so it's a very
straightforward argument from
their seven nice theorem to our seven
nights they're
sorry for us but uh
the truth will out and uh
oh
okay
so
that gets us
started
uh
the paper that we wrote has a whole
bunch of
other theorems in it and i want to tell
you one of
my favorites and then i want to tell you
some open questions and then
i'll stop uh
okay so um
you might have noticed that um
for the usual choice of coats co-set
representatives uh for the said consider
um
b suppose b is odd b
z contained in c
the usual choice of coset
representatives
namely zero up to b minus one there was
only
the only kinds of carries you could have
are nothing or b
uh two carries two types of carries
namely
0 and b
for the balance coset representatives
there were three kinds of carries for
balanced
uh
we had zero
you know b and minus b
and
well that's that's the truth
and
and a theorem is
if b is prime
uh
theorem
if
b
is prime
and i'm working not here but and i'm
working in cp the integers mod p
contained in the integers mod p squared
the carries table is the same
if i'm working in in this setting
and if you can choose coset
representatives
if
we have x
coset representatives
for uh for this subgroup in here uh
which have two kinds of carries such
that the carries matrix
has two kinds of carries
a a and b
zero and
b whatever they happen to be but they're
only two different numbers that appear
in that uh
p by p matrix then
it's the usual choice of coset
representatives well up to an offline
change then
there exists a contained in
cp squared store an invertible element
mod p squared and b
contained in cp squared uh such that
x such that if you translate a x plus b
that doesn't change anything the the
the carries
if x are coset representatives then then
a x or coset representatives anyway this
doesn't change things in a bad way that
this is either equal to zero
one up to p minus one or uh one
uh two
up to p
one of the two
um and so the usual choice of coset
representatives uh is characterized by
having only two kinds of carries up to
up to
up to a change and
um
the reason i decided to mention this
theorem first of all i like it uh and
you know what's special about the usual
choice of coset representatives well
this is one thing that's special about
it um
but it it it's
this the proof of this theorem
uses
the standard tools of of arithmetic
combinatorics um
uh
i won't prove anything but why
well if if x has
two kinds of if x
gives
two
two types
if the carries matrix only has two types
then uh
x plus x
then the size of x plus x
um is uh less than or equal to twice the
size of x x is x plus x is contained in
in in in this you know the two
translates of the set x
and
so
there's a classical theorem uh
kochi davenport something like that uh
which says that uh
um
i'll call it koshy davenport
uh
it's always the case that for any any
set x of this type uh x plus x uh is
bigger than or equal to
uh twice x
minus one so
if you only have two types of carries
the set
you know the the size of the set is very
severely constrained and one of the you
know main findings of arithmetic
combinatorics is that if
a set
has this form then you know it's very
close to an arithmetic progression and
so using basic theorems of fryman uh uh
were able to um
we had to change them um because we were
working mod p squared so there was a
little something to do but it wasn't so
bad and uh and and this theorem
uses the basic tools of arithmetic
combinatorics
some version just
in case you want something to think
about some version of this
is true
it doesn't have much to do with primes
but we can't touch that
we couldn't touch that for for more
general uh more general things um
so the last um the last two things i
want to do i want to make a comment and
pose one of many problems
the paper is full of both comments and
problems so if you're interested i hope
you take a look
let me first make a comment
uh
you can ask this carey's problem why why
normal i mean you know given a subgroup
of a group makes sense to choose coset
representatives it doesn't have to be
normal so for a while we thought the
theorem was true
more generally
do
we need
h normal in g
and
morty isaacs and bob garlick uh
found lots of counter examples i'll just
tell you one uh but still it's probably
something to understand uh so i'll
yes
so here's an example uh a family of
examples uh
just uh so there if if q is two to the n
where n is odd
uh
bigger than you know bigger than or
equal to three uh there's a
there's a group called the suzuki group
uh
of uh of q uh
is uh uh
one of the finite simple groups uh
i mean or very closely related to such
uh
is a group
of order
see if i remember uh q squared times q
minus one times q squared plus one
basically q to the fifth um
it's a it's a group of that order
there is a subgroup of this
size
there exists
h
which is the burel subgroup
size of h
is equal to q squared plus one
but there is no
subgroup of size uh
uh
you know there's no complement of it
no complement
okay so the extension doesn't split
but
um
the silo2 subgroup
there exists uh
let me call it k1 uh size of k1 that's
the celo2 subgroup
is q squared
and
so this is a 2-group this is definitely
not and so the intersection between
these two groups is is trivial and
the product is almost everything but
there's a little extra since uh
k1
times
k1
r can be chosen as coset representatives
but you need one more k1 and one more
any any one
and one more x
give
x coset representatives
of four uh
for uh
h in
this suzuki group
and
and how about the
well
since k1 is a group
the product of all of those things
is always still a coset representative
so c of x
uh is
is bigger than or equal to you might
have but it's uh the size of k1 squared
so i'll just write well i'll write the
size of k1 squared divided by the size
of of
x squared uh x is q squared plus one
what is x
x is the silo2 subgroup and one other
element
take the silo2 subgroup and take and
then complete it to coset
representatives by adding one further x
has to you know you have to choose a
coset representative
nope
it seems that x has been used in a few
different ways
sorry there's a little so
okay
this is a little x
uh so so capital x is k1 uh union
the singleton element
x okay that is we
k1 those are giving distinct
the translates of h by k1 are are all
distinct and then you need one more
coset representative to complete things
and this this ratio is very close to one
right
h
or
h in g h is a subgroup
right h is a subgroup and
k is
k
the translates of h by k are all
disjoint
right but they don't cover this but no
they they don't so you need one more if
you
count elements no i don't i i don't
i think i only need one more i think i
only need one more coset representative
that is this gives me this many
and
falling off that was a tough question
uh
okay so it
might
well let's see i thought i only needed
one more let's see so each
each
that's
okay so so far i have that many elements
right
right and then okay so i need to get
i'm so maybe i have to choose
q minus it'll still be okay i need to
choose
i thought i only needed to choose one
but um
cubed
right it's true okay so you're right uh
q minus one
okay
it won't
cause trouble okay it won't i hope we
can calculate now okay
no i don't think so
uh
that is
a full choice you know the the the
number of coset representatives i need
it's true i see
so maybe the gorilla said her size q
squared times q plus
q
minus one
okay so i'm i'm confused but thank you
that's fine i don't i don't mind i'm and
i'm doing disservice to to honor
honorable group theorists who did a
careful argument that i'm just not
remembering correctly but
but
if you do this properly you do
indeed get uh you do indeed get
c of x bigger than or equal to one minus
epsilon and uh so that
that is a claim and i haven't
established it and i don't i won't
pretend to but i
i
i will in one second i mean not not in
real time probably um this this argument
is quite general if you take um if you
take the any finite simple group and
take its brill i mean
we type and take its purl subgroup and
take the opposite but with ones on the
diagonal
then you can complete that and and and
there are lots of counter examples so
done correctly
uh that this is bigger than or equal to
one minus some uh you know one over q to
some power
and and
and and yet the extension doesn't split
so okay sorry for for saying that
incorrectly uh
um
let me take one more minute and say an
open problem uh
that we would love it if somebody would
solve but uh
i'm sorry for
messing that up
uh
and and that's um
you know we have a seven ninths theorem
so
given h a normal subgroup of g say a
finite index uh
let's let c of hg
be
equal be the maximum it can be
be the maximum
over
all choices
of x
um
and uh so we showed that uh that you
know
in some examples the the this this is uh
well
if the extension doesn't split you know
this this there's a seven nice but um
for um
for the you know integers
mod b inside the integers mod b squared
this can be three quarters
so the the uh and the the question is
just to determine what this maximum is
for example uh
what's the best
how
large can we make
is uh c mod b
z take just take two copies
b z
uh in three cross c
and we conjecture
that it's at nine sixteenths
which is three quarters squared plus
little of one and b is large
but but we can't prove that and so the
the paper is full of simple questions
like that that probably have reasonable
answers and
fernando xiao has a paper going
somewhere towards this but
but not quite there on the archive and
and this this particular question is
what's the best choice of coset
representatives for this subgroup in in
here is is is still open and then you
can take
you could take any group in any subgroup
and and fiddle around okay so that was a
a look at the subject of of of caries
and co cycles and it
it is the case that uh it makes very
heavy use of of the tools of of
arithmetic combinatorics and of these
nice results about theoretical from
theoretical computer science so
i'm impressed thank
you questions
or a patch of this argument yes
so if you take something like age to be
a product of loads of copies of c2 and
gpu loads of copies of c4
it's presumably really hard to get an
efficient system
such a setting yes that's right and so
then i repeat the question if you take h
to take g to be a bunch of c fours if
there's mod four and h to be a bunch of
c twos that extension doesn't split
because c2 inside of c4 doesn't split uh
and what's a good way of choosing coset
representatives
it reminds me of a very parallel
question and it's close but
the theorem that we proved is so
general i mean any
group in any finite index normal
subgroup there must be some
infinite version of it i mean there must
be some version for non
for non
finite index subgroups i mean so
we can prove that if you have a compact
group and a closed subgroup where the
quotient has finite heart measure
then if you pick two coset
representatives at random
uh
and if the
chance that there's still a coset
representative is bigger than seven
nights then the extension splits so we
have a continuous version if you like
but there must be you know we
we're not afraid of dealing with
infinite things we can take limits and
so i thought well take a whole bunch of
c force and a whole bunch of c2s and
then that's i wanted an example of uh of
uh infinite index
uh of an infinite index uh subgroup
where the extension doesn't split and
but i don't have any progress to say and
you were asking a nice finite question
which i i don't i mean do you think
that's somehow the worst
example sounds kind of extreme doesn't
it i mean c2 and c4
you know where it would be hard to make
an intelligent choice of uh
yeah we didn't we didn't think about it
i think it's it's fair to uh we we kept
reading your barbados notes and
discovering more things in them so uh
that's what we that's what we were
spending our time doing no
okay but uh if you haven't done it
that's one thing to learn look at ben's
barbados notes they're full of
useful
stuff
i guess the constant seven knives can be
improved under any reasonable
assumptions i don't know uh that's what
that's what this is sort of asking about
uh
you know if you have specific example
you you seem to be able to improve uh
seven nights but
and and what's the best you can do
what's the best choice of coset
representatives in specific examples
that was uh that was the what i meant to
to have the flavor but you're asking
maybe for a general theorem you know i
guess the counter example is already
disappointingly simple
inside of z9 but still okay i don't know
i don't i don't they should be
industrial but if c is bigger than some
than any epsilon then then there's some
bound complexity of
how close you are to splitting which
depends on your epsilon
that's
the usual experience
so by the way this this this example can
be fixed it's just that the the um
excuse for this one it's not the order
of the bureau it's the index of the
world oh yeah that's right that's right
that's thank you that's
right and i wrote down and crossed it
out twice in my notes but i left my
glasses home so i can't read my notes
but thank you i have you
thanks right q squared plus what is the
index of the braille that's right and
then
it is you just have to add one and it's
okay
bad to completely screw up marty isaac's
nice example but uh thank you
okay
okay